Okay. Um, we are now at
the part of the course.
We're coming up to fairly
modern times. The, uh,
it's been very breathless run from 6
million years of chimpanzee evolution
through many,
few million years of human evolution.
And we're coming up to
more or less than 1960s,
which is the period of the,
the,
the greatest percentage increase
in human population on earth ever.
Uh,
so this is the peak of what's called the
population explosion and we're gonna be
talking about that till almost
the end of the term now.
So I have to tell you,
uh, a little bit, uh,
truth in truth in a teaching or something.
How I got interested in this topic
when I was a just a little
bit older than you are now.
I did the fairly usual thing of going,
putting on my short pants and going
around the world and around Asia anyway,
uh, with almost no money in
my pocket. And uh, you all,
if you haven't ever done that,
you should do it.
Definitely an after you graduate college.
It was a great time to do it.
And one of the places I went to
was Hong Kong. Now Hong Kong.
At that time there were huge numbers
of people coming out of China.
China was still extraordinarily poor at
the time and anytime anybody could leave,
they left. And so Hong Kong
was incredibly crowded, uh,
with very poor people. And it's still
incredibly crowded place of course.
And migrants are still
coming out, uh, if they can.
So one of the, uh, what, where
would these people going to live?
They were hillsides with shanty towns,
lots and lots of shanty towns,
but also the low, the, it's right on
the ocean. It's an island, a part of,
it's an island.
So the water is free.
So many people were living in little
sampans little boats called sand pans in
just in the harbor dock to
sort of almost anywhere.
And I thought, well, that's
interesting. And one of my friends,
I had number of Chinese friends took
me to look at the boats and it was
interesting. I, you know, I wasn't
yet really interested in demography,
but I couldn't help notice that. Basically
every boat had a little girl on it, 11,
12, 13 or something, uh, maybe younger.
And then, uh, we got invited
on the boat one of the first,
but one of the boats and uh,
you know,
people extremely polite even though
very poor, very polite and you know,
a lot of bowing and
shaking hands from my part.
And they wanted to offer me something,
a little bit of tea,
a little bit of rice cake,
you know, they're just as
wonderful as they could be.
And I noticed that when something
had to be done, like the tea,
how to be gotten or this
side of the other thing,
it was that little girl that was doing
all the work then. Okay, so what,
that's the one of the kids that's,
you know,
it's good for kids to have some
chores and then since you know,
they didn't have television nerd,
a lot of entertainment and here was this
Westerner and they weren't so used to
seeing a lot of westerners on their boats.
I sorta got passed from boat to boat.
When you go walking around the world,
that's a very good thing.
If you go to places where
they don't see Westerners,
you can get passed on very easily.
So in boat after boat and this phenomenon
repeated itself that there was this
little girl in every boat and she
seemed to be doing all the work.
And so finally I asked my friends,
you know, what's what's going on here?
And a little hard to get the information
out of them, but actual factors,
the form of a,
shall we say,
family population control
that uh, the, there,
this was a non contracepting population.
So children just kept coming and they
couldn't support the number of children
that they had and they did
not value girls very much.
So what they did is basically they sold
the girls from one boat to the next boat
and then the little girls were
basically servants. Again,
you can use the word slave if you want,
but servants in whatever
boat they had been sold to.
And some money changed hands.
Of course,
all illegal because Hong Kong was
in a hundred British rules. I mean,
it's legal almost
everywhere anyway. Um, and,
uh, they were just working, doing as much
work as could be, gotten out of them.
Well that was very sad. Um, but
wasn't a disaster because you know,
everybody was living very poorly.
Then later, same trip, uh,
with my medical connections,
I got to tour one of the big British
build Queen Elizabeth Hospital,
one of these big, there's big city
hospitals have ward after ward.
And one of the things I was taken to
see tuberculosis was a very big problem
back then. Leprosy was a problem
with tuberculosis was a problem too.
I did something stupid with leprosy.
I visited,
there was a leper colony on an island
of Hong Kong and they were constructing
stuff. And uh, and I cannot stand around
what people are working in me not.
So I grabbed a pitch for um,
uh,
a pick ax and started working with them.
And of course the pick ax is rough.
It's made of not terribly
well polished wood.
And there I was banging away with
it and it rubs whatever. So, uh, uh,
leprosy is a bacteria that gets into
your skin and the only way to get her to
get that leprosy into your skin.
So,
so the lepers had been working with it
and rubbing it into their skin and they
were rubbing it into the wood of
the accident on to me, I did not,
I was really stupid in retrospect, but
you know, you do a lot of stupid things.
Um, and I did not catch leprosy in
it. And in fact, by that time, uh,
most they had a drug,
an antibiotic against leprosy,
and most of the leper leprosy,
bacillus in these people were dead.
So it probably wasn't quite as dangerous
as, as, as, as it might have been. Anyway.
I did not catch leprosy.
Sorry, I'm throwing. You can
shake my hand and so forth.
But the people there, and you don't
have the old, this is an aside,
but it's about poverty
and in Philadelphia.
So leprosy affects the nerve cells
and it doesn't make directly make your
fingers or nose full off, but you don't
feel wounds. So, you know, he goes,
you don't have the nerve cells. So you
don't take care of wounds, adventure,
the fingers gets infested
and infected and damaged.
Damage is kind of constant and
parts of you fall off actually.
But it's not the leprosy bacteria itself,
which only attacks nerves.
It's the damage that you're not paying,
you're not noticing, you're not aware of.
So, okay, sorry. That was an excursion.
So leprosy was a big thing in Hong
Kong at the time as was tuberculosis.
And then the big British hospital,
I went in and,
and one of the things I saw
was huge wards, you know,
big places with again,
so a ward full of these just pubescent
or prepubescent girls and they all had
TB. And then there was two or
three of these wards actually.
So very large number of girls
there. And I said, what's going on?
You know, and then the story, the
full story came out that yes, indeed,
there's a lot of selling, uh, of the, of
the children between boats and, and yes,
they work and because they're underfed
and overworked and TB is rampant,
these girls get tuberculosis.
And then what happens is they take them
to the health station and, and the,
the doctor say,
you got to build up this girl and they
give them milk powder milk is taking them.
What do you think they
do at the milk powder
given to the boy child,
right?
So the girl gets sicker and then she's
getting quite sick and she's brought back
and now she's given medicine a antibiotic.
And guess what happens with the
medicine taking to the market?
Sold money is used boy rice or millet
for the boy children eventually.
So TB is probably where it gets the lungs.
It can also get in the long bones of
the body and the venture and infects the
long bones and the long bone start.
There are huge amounts of pus builds
up and eventually it breaks through the
skin. So what someone who has a child
with this kind of long bone, uh,
uh,
tuberculosis sees basically pus the skin,
eventually breaks in the Puss,
starts pouring out and uh,
the parents are terribly afraid and
they're afraid for their biological kids.
They're biological sons especially.
So as soon as this happens to the girl,
they just dumped dumper at the British at,
at whatever the public hospital is.
And um,
I, and, and they just
just abandoned them there.
And what the doctors told me was that
the girls are now 13 and 14 and the lip,
the tuberculosis is so far gone that
there's nothing they can do in the girls
die. So this was, you know,
my first introduction to that
nexus of extreme poverty,
extreme over crowded conditions,
overpopulation.
And I'm not saying the causal
relationship between those two.
It's a complicated story,
which we will, we will get to.
But that nexus of you always see whenever
you see incredibly dense populations,
you always see this kind of poverty and
the kinds of things that people undergo,
you know? Yeah. I was trying to put
myself in the mind of a parent. You know,
what kind of a situation of
the end that they sell their,
their daughters to fairly certain death.
And the situation is,
as I've described to you
now, even though I saw this as a huge,
as a very large phenomenon, a surprise,
I've never seen this in the,
in any literature.
I've never seen an
academic paper about it.
I've never seen a newspaper
story about it. Uh,
it's not discussed in demographic
circles and some public health circles,
which I'm aware of. I, it, it
just isn't, isn't brought up.
And so I'm thinking to myself, you know,
I was not a, a scholar of this thing.
And I said,
have I miss remembered this?
You very frequently you miss
remember things. Have I blown up?
Did I see one or two cases and have
somehow aggrandizement? I eventually,
after telling the story quite a bit, even
in their early runnings of this class,
I started doubting that this, you know,
that somehow I why such a big thing,
why wasn't it shown in one year I
decided, okay, this is the last year.
I'm not going to tell this
story again because you know,
I don't have any references for it and
everything. I, I say I try to, you know,
student comes to me,
I can give you a reference and you can
see in the notes a lot of things have
little references which you probably can't
read, but if you call me or email me,
I'll tell you what that
little scribble means. Anyway,
at the end of that lecture,
actually it was about two lectures later,
uh, cause it was an exam
coming up right after that.
After more than this
class in previous years,
students used to come up and
we used to spend half an hour,
an hour discussing whatever they want to
discuss and one girl stayed by the side
and then when everybody is gone,
she came up to me a
little bit shy and said,
thank you for telling that story.
My mother was one of
those girls and she would,
she knew from her mother was
basically what I had said.
But the difference was that this was her
bio biological mother and this wasn't
an abandoned girl. She said she remembered
being in the hospital with all girls,
basically the mother, I'm
sorry, I text him. So I said,
oh my gosh,
you know,
would your mother come to class and
describe what this situation was like?
And the, and yes, the mother was in fact
a professor at a college in New Jersey,
not Princeton.
And she came up here and,
and described it and again described
it in great detail, you know,
more or less as, as, as I've described it.
And she said that when she was in the
hospital and she's all the other little
girls who more or less the same age,
same medical problem.
And she said as a little girl,
she was wondering why their parents,
their mother didn't come to visit them.
Why their parents didn't come to visit
her. She was one of the few whose,
whose mother I guess the father.
I don't really remember that detail.
Did come to visit.
Well,
the doctors kind of noticed that this
girl had a bio parent and so they took her
out of the big ward and put a lot of
incredibly special effort into this one
girl.
And eventually she got the
bacteria out of her and survived.
She was, uh, uh, you know, walk like this,
missing a hip and had a fair number
of, of sequella from the bone, uh,
TB. Uh, but she might,
she got cured, grew up,
managed to get educated, migrate to
America, and became a professor at, at,
as I say, a college in New Jersey and had
a daughter at Yale taking this course.
So it's one of the miracle stories.
Uh,
but I'm convinced now that,
and I didn't dream this stuff up.
Okay. So that's really my
personal motivation, that star,
my personal motivation for being,
doing all this uh,
course stuff. Now, uh,
what's the word we described
for this era of the sixties?
The population explosion.
Why do we use the word explosion?
It's a rather, uh, you know,
emotive kind of word and it's for this
reason that here is a somewhat fanciful
recreation of history, but we know it's
can't be very much different than this.
Cause we know what the, we start
knowing what the populations were here.
So we put in some sort of a reasonable
growth rate in the population going to
look like that. The only thing you
can really see is the black death.
Then as we've talked about in this class,
starting roughly in the 17
hundreds population just takes off
and you've heard of
exponential population growth,
and you may or may not
know what that means,
but what precisely means is
there's a certain rate of growth,
a certain percent per year in each year,
the population grows by that same percent,
1% a year or 2% a year,
3% a year.
But the percentage growth is the
numbers of people added every year grows
because the base grows. But the
percentage edit every year is constant.
That's exponential growth. In
fact, during this period, in fact,
during most of this period,
the percentage rate of growth has
been increasing and an increased from
somewhere out here of you know,
0.001% to then 0.0 1.1 and
in this period it went up to,
uh, two, even 3% global,
the whole world population growth
rate in this incredible, uh,
ex expansion. As you can sort of
see, again in this somewhat scheme,
Matteis used a graph that the incredible
rate of growth has slowed down a little
bit and we'll, we'll talk about what
that means, but it's still growing, uh,
outrage or they project that,
that it should slow down. This is,
we are now at about 6.7 billion.
So some of that graph
is, is, is a projection.
So you can call this kind of population
of hyper exponential where the,
the rate,
not only does the growth get
faster in an exponential way way,
but the rate of growth itself grows.
So it's hyper exponential growth.
Now there's a, the whole issue of
population growth is very politicized.
Uh, uh, some people don't think that
we should pay. It is no problem.
Some people think we shouldn't
go into anything about it.
Some people think it's too
politically sensitive, uh, to, to,
to say anything about it.
And
in this discussion, one of
the things you hear is, oh,
the world's population has
been growing for a long time.
We've been able to cope with it. And
Arik economics is, is wonderful. We can,
we've industrialized.
The population has been growing and
people have been getting richer.
And that is certainly
true since Malthus wrote,
the population has multiplied many times,
and yet these mass mass starvations
have not happened. In fact,
not only as the population has grown,
people have gotten richer.
So they say we've coped with this in the
past. We can cope with it in the future.
The problem is that this is unprecedented,
that we don't really have any significant
length of history for something like
this. So anybody who's had
tells you that they have,
they know what's going to
happen in the future is just,
he's just ignorant. This is absolutely
in unknown territory, unknown territory.
It doesn't mean I'm not saying they was
going to absolutely be a disaster or
it's absolutely going to be fine.
It's just that we have no way of
predicting basically anything with the
population growing like that.
Um, up to a few years ago,
basically nobody predicted all
the environmental, for instance,
nobody predicted all the environmental
problems that we're having now that came,
uh,
essentially out of the blue.
Now this is a scheme Matteis thing.
Here's kind of a more cartoonish kind of,
uh,
even workout change,
but it doesn't go quite so far back.
So it's a little bit better data here.
And again, showing the same thing.
This was a, you are here,
this was drawn in 2004.
We're now in 2008 and we're about 6.7.
So in,
in the, just the four years since this
was made, we're still on this trajectory.
No,
nothing very unexpected has happened.
Here is the, uh, the US census
bureau a projection, uh,
uh, update December, 2008.
So it's as recent as you can
find for what's happened. They,
they do a hundred years and
you may know it as 3 billion,
4 billion, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Just keeps going and out at
the end they're protecting
a little bit of fall off.
But when doesn't know that by 2040,
they're expecting 9 billion
people and still growing.
So there's no, well you've
heard a lot about, you know, uh,
Europe and,
and Michael titled,
Mom gave you a lecture on
the low population growth
rates in Europe and Japan
in, in, in quite a number
of countries in the world.
And that's correct that the population
growth is extremely unbalanced in the
world. The developed countries
are having zero two at most,
5% of the increase they're
growing at you know,
0.1% whereas some of the poorer
countries are still growing at two,
3%.
So I'll show you in a minute
that basically all of this
growth is in the poorer
countries where they're least least have
the least resources to cope with this
amount of growth. Now here is, uh,
the,
the population change in millions and
we will see that that has basically been
growing.
This is where we are now
basically grew up to 1990.
It's a fallen off a little bit here and
then it's predicted to keep growing for
another, a few years and then
it's predicted to go down here.
I emphasize guesswork. I,
this was not on the original.
This is data and we have fairly
decent reason. But again,
this error bars on here and we
don't know what those error bars,
how big they should be and
this is really guesswork.
The guesswork is not too bad for
the near future because the, the,
the, the women who are going to have
these children are ready, born the ready,
close to maturity.
Uh,
we know that fertility rates
generally don't change all that fast,
although I will show you plenty of
exceptions to that in the next lecture.
So you can maybe more or less believe
the next dozen years here or something
that, and then, uh,
you'll make various projections and
I'll show you those projections can be
almost anything because we don't
have a very good basis for that.
But the rear near term projection that
the number of people at it every year is
going to go up.
It's probably a
pretty accurate because
it's very near term.
And now again,
what are the,
the optimist take that data that here's
the number of people added and you'll
see it's has been going up.
It's kind of jiggling around.
It may or may not decline in the future,
but
because the base has been growing
because the population keep scrolling,
if the same number of
people are added every year,
then the percentage increase goes down.
So when you hear a lot of optimism
about the population situation,
what they're talking about is that the,
that the peak
rate of growth here in the 1960s has
come down as a percentage of the base.
But as you just saw, since the base
is growing, the number of Apps,
Lou actual number of people added
is not changed all that much.
And again,
we're growing the world's going something
like one and a one and a quarter
percent when one to one and a
half percent a year currently.
And the guesswork is, and the hope is
that we'll continue down. In fact, the,
this, this, uh,
continued decreases based on some pretty
optimistic assumptions and they'll
just,
we may get time to talk about them later,
but fertility has been falling.
If you presume that fertility is fallen
as far as it going to a four and now
it's going to stay constant.
So the most conservative
projection is constant fertility.
Whatever we are at now,
that's the way it's going to be.
Then you don't get anything like this.
You get an a huge takeoff.
This presumes that fertility will keep
falling until people have two children
per family and fairly rapidly.
And uh,
that's a nice guess, a nice prediction.
But we really have essentially no theory,
no decent theoretical
basis to presume that.
Now here is the one number you
should really keep in your mind.
This is right up to date.
This is the Census Bureau 2009 this gives
you the world events and it just Britt
for being kind of cute. It breaks it down
to how much is the increase each year,
month, day. You can do it down
to the second and notice, and I,
and I gave you these numbers last
time in as ratios as per thousand.
This is the number of births.
Yeah,
this is the number of births per year.
135 million. And the number of deaths,
55 million. So that's the difference.
That's the population growth rate,
80 million people.
So that's,
I think one of the key numbers to just
keep in mind rounded off 80 million that
the increase every year on
earth now is 80 million.
And it's been a roughly
that for quite some time.
The,
uh,
the maximum here was
something like 90 million,
knocked, not quite 90 million, and
now we're just about 80 million.
So when people say though the birth,
everything's coming down,
things are getting better, we're
going to come to a soft landing. Well,
what we actually know is the difference
between 87 million and 80 million with
large and unknown error bars. So might
not be a decrease at all. I mean,
we just don't know.
But nothing drastic has happened to
engender such optimism about the future of
human population. Although you will
hear that over and over and over again.
Now,
um,
as,
as I showed you this, this
graph that, uh, we are here
at, at the, uh, at the
sure here to 6.7 billion and all of
the projections show it to continue to
increase.
Again,
the rate of increase gets fuzzier and
fuzzier as you go further out in time,
but it will increase.
And uh,
the projections are that by 2040
will be 9 billion and still growing.
So we're adding a billion
at 80 million a year.
We're adding a billion
every 12 and a half years.
If it falls a little bit,
we'll add a billion every
13 years or 14 years.
And what's to keep in mind and
when you think of those numbers,
so that's a billion people
every 12, 13, 14 years,
pick whatever number you like
and think of everybody's green.
Anybody Green in this class?
Anybody not green or you environmentalist.
Yes.
Who's an anti environmentalist?
Hello? One, two.
Well, I'm going to return
to this theme, but uh,
they can't be repeated enough times that
think of the environmental footprint of
a billion extra people.
Every dozen or so years,
a billion extra people. Now add up
all the environmentalist, moldy,
the achievements of this wonderful
environmental movement there.
There it's a wonderful thing and it
pales in comparison that, that, you know,
it's just we're playing a losing
battle with the environment.
As long as we're growing at a
billion people in so many years,
we're not going to solve the environmental
problems no matter what we we do.
It's just too, too great an
increase of people. And yet,
environmentalist generally never
talk about a human population.
It's too politically
dangerous to talk about that.
Hence this course,
one of the very in the country or anywhere
in the world that that really hits,
talks about population a straight on.
Okay,
so why do we, why are we, why are we,
why is everybody projecting that the
population is going to keep increasing
their, and it's simply, you look at
the age structure and something like,
half of the world's population,
uh, is under 15 years old.
He just coming in, uh, I'm sorry,
a third of the world's
population is under 15 years old.
And so just coming into reproductive
ages and we know that for the next they
will come into reproductive ages and
then B of reproductive potential for the
following 30 years.
And we know that this increasing number
of now 10 to 15 year olds who will
become into reproductive ages,
we'll keep the population increasing.
So that's certain that it will increase
a low, the rate of increase and, and,
and how it changes is
certainly a less certain.
So,
but it's under almost any
kind of reasonable assumption.
Uh, the population is going to grow, uh,
another several billion people.
And so again, you know, we're
in unprecedented territory.
Most people think the earth right
now is incredibly stressed and it is
environmental things, uh, situation.
And now add another couple of
billion people to that, uh,
in the near future and
see what's going on.
So since we don't have crystal balls,
the students usually ask me question,
what's going to happen? And
I always have to say, oh,
I left my crystal ball and my closet. You
know, I didn't, didn't bring it today.
I do not have have a way into the future,
but anybody who tells you they know
what's going to happen in the future and
especially if they're going
to be optimistic about it,
is very blind kind of person.
Okay.
So you've all heard discussions of the
population problem and it's really two
different problems.
The first problem,
which in the West we're very cognizant
of is over consumption by rich people.
If they're a good fraction of the world
is now what you should definitely call
rich.
And they consume like crazy and a
lot of what we consume is frivolous,
like hummers great big, you know, some,
some little person on driving this great
big SUV that they never carry anything
heavy and they certainly don't have to
drive over logs or something which an SUV
is actually good for. So
the over consumption, uh,
depletes the world's resources,
increases pollution,
destruction of habitat, et
Cetera, et Cetera, et cetera.
So environmental misery is largely caused
by rich people consuming profligate
Lee unnecessarily.
And profligately.
The other side of the coin is a poverty.
You have the world is definitely split
and the split is getting wider between
poverty and and over
people to over consume.
And their problem of course is under
consumption and they lead to all of the
problems of poverty, which I've
discussed. Hong Kong and you,
I don't have to tell you very much about
what the problems in the world poor
people are.
So we have these two opposite problems,
what I call environmental
misery and human misery.
And they're both very largely result of
two rapid population growth that that we
might add some utopian scenario
eventually be able to cope with say the
population levels that we have now
maybe. Uh, but at the rate of growth,
it's obvious just looking around you
that our technology, our economy,
our governments have not been
able to cope with this so far.
So it's very interesting as,
as a,
as a political note that there
are these two faces of the pop.
They run the environmental problem and
the, and the, the people misery problem.
And it's amazing how people
focus on one or the other.
There's people like in work,
in planned parenthood and various
feminist and women's organizations,
they're instant in people misery.
There is talking about poverty
and the attendant problems.
Then there's environmentalist.
They worried about trees and the survival
of animals and forests and nature and
both have of course very important
and very, uh, good causes to work on.
But it is absolutely mind boggling how
rarely you find anybody that sort of is
really in any way concerned about both
problems or in any way realizes how
population is the centerpiece,
uh, of both of these problems.
Okay.
So let me talk just a little
bit about over consumption and,
uh, who's the number one bad guy
and over consumption? We are,
right. So here's the story for, uh,
some of the story for the United States.
This is, um, uh, the, the, the,
the growth in the United States
population from 1900 to 2000.
We in 1900 had about 75 million.
And in 2006, uh, this,
yeah, that's 2000, 2007,
2006,
we passed 300 million people.
And that's a quadrupling that
our population has quadrupled in,
uh,
that one century.
We were almost like an underdeveloped
country in our population growth rate.
And that is up to the almost current.
And here is again the latest census
bureau thing from a, again, this was a,
just got it out of the computer last
night actually the latest numbers that
here's the,
the,
and one of the standard things is
give you a hundred year of timeframe.
Currently they're using
1950 to 2050 and we are,
as you know,
sort of right about here and here's
the u s population growth rate and just
almost a perfectly straight line.
There is no prediction that the u s is
going to slow down and it's a population
growth rate.
We're growing at about 3 million a year.
It's currently, that's
1% of the year, a year.
And because of of natural increase that's
births over deaths of people already
in America plus immigration,
we're just going up here and um,
in our population growth rate,
it's about two thirds, uh,
birth silver deaths of citizens already
here and about one third immigration.
And of immigration of the guesses are
that it's about two thirds legal and one
third illegal.
They obviously be illegal is an enormous
guests that the absolute number of the
percentage of anything that it is.
If you look at how they
come up with these numbers,
it's really seat of the pants.
We don't know very much about the
magnitude of illegal immigration,
but it's an enormous political issue.
Now on the consumption side,
uh,
of course we consume so much and
again numbers very kind of wildly,
but the range of numbers are that an an
American consumes something between 20
and 40 times what a person in a
developing country will consume.
So if you multiply the r 3
million population growth
the year by a consumption
factor of 20, that's equivalent
to the growth population.
Growth is 60 million poor people.
And so you do it that way.
It looks like that our population growth,
uh,
is as damaging to the resource
and environmental situation,
the world as the whole rest of
the world, uh, put together.
And that's just considering
our population increased,
not the population base which has
also consuming at this great rate.
So we are indeed,
it is certainly correct that we are a
tremendous strain on on the environment
and resources of the earth and as I
shared it's not getting better or our
population is just increasing.
Now you have to balance against that
that a lot of our population growth is a
course people coming in from other
countries so that it's not in some sense
Americans who are getting richer but
it's poor people coming in and getting
richer.
But you can play these numbers in all
different ways and we'll talk about the
politics in a moment.
But the US Census Bureau used to say
that we will reach that the US population
will reach 300 million by the year 2050
we reached that number 44 years earlier
than the Census Bureau thought and we
are still growing and now the census
bureau says there was no
sign of stabilization at all.
They cannot give you a number at which
they think the u s population will
stabilize. Because as far out
as anybody can kind of project,
there's no reason to believe
that stabilization in view.
Now some of the argumentation
is that you again,
people,
there's very political issue and a
half the people say it's all those poor
people that are over reproducing can't
they learn some self control and then
handpieces all those Americans
and Japanese that consume
like crazy can't they
use some self control and
it's an extremely sterile
argument that goes on and
on. People don't think beyond, you know,
two or three sentences
in into that argument.
And uh, as I tell you, if
you do it out numerically,
the, the increasing damage is,
is it's more or less equal.
And it depends more critically,
as,
as Americans usually blame,
blame ourselves that where the problem,
there's a very kind of, um, do you want
to call it, use the word racist, but,
but a very euro Miraco
centric argument that,
because the presumption is when it says,
well,
we are the consumers and poor of the poor
people we don't have to worry about is
that they will stay poor.
It's a western assumption that poor
people are going to stay poor and they're
not, not only did they not consumers now,
but they're never going to be consumers.
And that is just nonsense.
And we've seen now the Chinese
have come up enormously.
The Indians would come up enormously. The
Indonesians have come up enormously, uh,
everywhere in the world.
These vast numbers of poor people are
now our star now starting to be serious
consumers. And I think the, the CO2, uh,
production in China, I think has just in
outpaced the United States. But I didn't,
I didn't look that up. Uh, uh, recently.
And so they are an equal problem.
So if one gets out of one's head,
the idea that poor people are
gonna stay poor forever. Uh,
which is an a pre globalization idea.
Now a worker in China can compete with
a worker in America and eventually
there's going to be some leveling.
So I think the proper thing is if you
think there are too many people on earth
for either human misery issues or
environmental misery issues or both,
any birth, you should consider
more or less equal, uh,
preventing birth in America,
in Japan and Indonesia.
Everywhere that in the
not too distant future,
these people are going
to be more or less equal.
And we'll see.
We'll,
we'll see next lecture what the people
themselves want respect to this thing.
But I hope after this course that none
of you get involved in a sterile argument
of US versus them. You know, it's,
it's, it, it doesn't get you anywhere.
Okay. What in the world
as it is today? Uh,
most of the popular,
almost all of the population growth is
in the poorest countries against ethics
are pretty bad to something like 95% of
population growth in the world are in
the poorest countries.
And as you know,
new people need schools, they need
healthcare, they need a place to live,
they need jobs. And all of this
takes money. It takes capital.
And that's what the poor countries
are missing. They don't have, uh,
the capital, they usually don't
have the technological expertise,
they don't have the often the quality
of government that can cope with these
enormous problems.
So it's,
it's the places that are least capable
of coping with the population increase
that are in fact salad with it.
And the magnitude of this
growth is, is incredible. Um,
as far as that as we can project,
uh,
the poor countries are going to have
to build a city equivalent of 1 million
people,
1 million city,
to cope with a million people
every week for the next 45 years,
which is far as we projected.
And if you look at, you know,
you know the big cities,
Shanghai, Beijing, and China,
just pick almost any name and got
her an Almanac and you'll see the,
there's, there's so many mega million
cities in China that, you know,
cities even that I've never heard
of and you look up their population,
they're in,
in the millions and place like New
York with 7 million people is nothing.
So Sweden where I lived
in Sweden for a while, uh,
has like seven to 8 million people.
New York City has seven to 8
million people, cities in China.
That's, that's, that's a small
town. Uh, almost. And India is not,
not far behind.
So people in the United States generally
don't have much of an idea of what
poverty really looks like.
And one of the best descriptions of this
comes from a bill Ryerson who is going
to be a guest lecturer later.
And he describes flying into
Bombay again a few years back.
But in this period of extreme population
explosion that we're talking about,
go to the airport and the airport
is way outside the city as,
as all our parts have to be.
And by the international flight schedules,
they come in early in the morning.
So he starts driving in and
almost immediately at the
airport you start seeing,
uh, poor people begging on the
street. You see a Shanti's, uh,
that, that people are living in. And
when it comes into the denser places,
people start begging and
you'll see very common.
Your mother holding an
infant and you can look,
the infants is clearly nearly
dead. And the mother, you know,
please give me something, anything so I
can keep this child alive till tomorrow.
And there's one after the other,
after the other and it gets denser and
then the sun comes up and it gets warm
and is generally a rather warm country.
And there's all these jitneys
and motorbikes trucks,
small trucks putting around and they
don't have good catalytic converters.
Those are expensive.
A lot of them have platinum in them.
So they produce a lot of pollution and
the air gets very thick with this black
smoke, very early and black, some sort,
whatever you want to call it in, in,
in the early morning. So you're not
breathing fresh air. And then of course,
they have no toilets, uh, around,
and you're going to read some
articles about what that means.
And so very soon,
the stench of human waste,
you're on a main streets going into the
main city. The stench of human waste, uh,
comes up at you and the smells
terribly and the more and more beggars,
and it's just, you know, an heart
absolutely heart wrenching, uh,
a description of what's going on.
And then you think that here are
millions and millions of people that,
uh, have, you know, we'll
never have a real house.
They live in some cardboard
shack somewhere. Uh,
they'll never have a real job.
They'll never probably go to the bathroom
in a toilet and they may never even
breathe a breath of fresh air. Um, so it,
poverty is really a very,
very serious kind of situation.
And,
uh,
you go to lots and lots of cities in
the world and see similar kinds of
descriptions.
And I do the numbers on this poverty.
So we compare it to the United States.
So General Motors before
its recent demise,
these numbers are three or four years old.
They tell it.
So they pay wages to the workers.
Then they have health benefits,
which you've read about is very high
because they pay them for the rest of the
life and they pay pensions.
So when you add all that up,
how much lifetime they're going to pay
for worker and divided by the number of
hours the worker works,
it comes out for,
for General Motors was $80 an hour
at the wages, general motor worker,
$80 an hour.
And uh,
that was somewhere near a
maximum for union wages,
not counting like airline pilots.
So we get an awful lot more than that.
The upper middle class, uh,
that's blue collar workers at GM,
the upper middle class people mostly
in this room are going to be earning an
awful lot, uh, more than that.
On the other hand is the poverty level.
Uh,
which for a family of a mother,
father,
and three children is defined as,
uh,
um,
$24,000 a year.
That's the 2006 number.
Now, the official US number,
which is $13 and 35
cents a day per person,
that's the poverty level as officially
defined in the United States. [inaudible],
Walmart, uh, a worker,
a sales associate earn $6 and 10
cents an hour or $12,000 a year,
6,000, uh, an hour, uh, uh,
I'm sorry, is 12,000 a year.
They are below poverty level.
So the next step up for a Walmart
worker is po is official poverty level.
When you go to developing countries,
you have to cut to get any idea of a
scale, you'd have to cut the Walmart,
Walmart wages in at
least a factor of four.
So Walmart, uh, makes, uh,
pants in El Salvador and the pants sell
for this particular article on the $16
and 95 cents in their United States
stores. And how much you think the women,
uh, in El Salvador get who
make the pants per pant?
15 cents is the wage level
that they,
they get for it.
The UN reported that about
half of the world's workers,
which is about 1.4 billion people,
uh,
earn less than $2 a day.
So the average wage,
the median wage in the world
is something like $2 a day.
That's per wage earner, not per family,
not per person, but per wage earner.
And that then has to be divided among
however many dependence that person has.
You, I've told you that what the u s
sets, uh, it's official level for poverty.
Every country in the world of course,
gets to decide its own
level of what poverty is.
And the official poverty
level in the poorest 10,
10 to 20 poorest 20
countries is a dollar 25.
You're only poor if you earn less than
a dollar 25 per capita per day in both
China and India,
the official poverty level
is closer to $1 a day.
And this is at 2005 prices.
Again,
statistics are always a
couple of years behind things
in rich places like Latin
America and Eastern Europe. Uh,
$2 a day is the more
appropriate, uh, poverty level.
And that is for all the
developing countries.
$2 a day is the median and their
own self defined poverty level.
But within each country,
in each region, uh,
there's great inequality
of course in income.
So about a third of the people in Latin
America are living on less than $2 a
day. Two thirds of the people in
Pakistan live on less than two thirds,
$2 a day, uh, more than
58% of the population.
Kenya lives on less than $1 a day.
Brazil,
25% of the people on less than $1 a day.
The whole of sub Saharan Africa,
44% of the people in less than $1 a day.
And so then it's not only these,
you know, traditionally poor
countries, but in Romania, uh,
after the Soviet block fell apart,
40% of the people live
on less than $1 a day.
Indonesia had a,
had a government work programs that
people could get some kind of work,
and Labor has got 75 cents a day
for five hours of work a day.
That's 15 cents an hour. And I don't know
how much it, how much time it takes to,
so Walmart pants, but maybe
an hour, probably less. So.
15 cents an hour is a wage that for
many people in places like Indonesia,
which is a lot of oil, it's not an
overall necessarily a poor place.
15 cents an hour for an hour's work,
75 cents a day. And that's much
more than they can get working,
you know, getting agricultural
jobs around where they live. Uh,
so here's a description from Zambia.
A nine year old boy alone,
a Banda,
his job is to beat rock fragments
into powder. He doesn't have a hammer.
He found a large steel bolt from some
construction site. He found a boat.
He grips in his bare hand and pounds
the rock with it. He takes raw rock,
takes a bolt that he found and,
and pounds with it and he can
fill it. Takes him about, uh,
uh,
in a week he can fill about a
half a bag with this powder,
which is used for construction.
And he gets about a dollar
50 for the half bag.
And it's used for making
concrete in Kenya, for instance,
uh,
children and start working at five or six.
We saw,
we talked about Charles Dickens was so
much of his writing was about children
going to work at age seven.
Well seven is old.
They go to five or six and they work as
prostitutes. Even at that age, miners,
construction workers,
pesticide Strayer's and all the
kinds of dangerous and miserable job.
Uh, in sub Saharan Africa there's
something like 48 million children,
14 and younger, who, who were
working. And four years later,
these are says 2000.
By 2004,
it had increased by 1.3 million.
So the number of children working in
these poverty level jobs is increasing
because the whole population
is increasing and,
and so forth.
And
this is the poverty rates around
the world. Just to compare, uh,
this confirms the numbers
that I'm telling you
that uh,
these are the, the head
count, the number of millions,
a percent below poverty
line at dollar 25 a day,
less than $2 a day.
And if you take out China a China
is still one of the poorest places.
When you add in all the peasants,
it doesn't get it. Get some,
actually China makes it
worse than you add in China,
you have a higher percentage at,
at these poverty levels.
Same for whatever poverty
level you want to work these,
the appropriate poverty levels
for developing countries.
Um,
now again,
you have the same two
ways of describing this.
The absolute number of people in
this kind of poverty is growing up.
That's the whole population grows.
The number of people in
these levels are growing up.
Yet there has been economic progress
in the sense that as a percentage of
people,
the poverty low numbers are going down.
So there's more people in poverty,
but there's a lesser percentage of the
total population in poverty. So again,
you can,
depending on your political orientation,
you can describe this as an increasingly
bad situation where more and more
people are in this kind of poverty or a
situation that is getting better because
the percentage of people
in poverty is going down.
Now the miracle. So you've all
heard of the economic miracle,
uh,
in East Asia especially and anybody
come fairly recently from China?
No, none of the students come from
time. Well, the average income,
and again upon how you define of
course the Chinese donor dollars.
So when you express it in dollars,
there's a translation and the best
way of doing is what's called P P P
purchasing power parody. One way is
to use the official exchange rate.
How many of you know they are in so many
won and how many dollars can they buy
with that one? But that exchange rate,
as you know, especially in China,
is manipulated by the government
and is not a real number.
So number that makes the Chinese income
look more favorable and is close to a
real number is what they called
purchasing power parity. You say,
how much does a sack
of rice costs in China?
How much does it cost
in the United States?
And you try to use a basket of commodities
appropriate to what the people in
that country actually use and say,
how much would that cost in dollars?
So you can have a parody and,
and that kind of a level, uh,
Chinese peasant on average,
earns a dollar a day,
lives the person ever a dollar a day is
the average income in a Chinese peasant
family.
The jobs in the modern sector,
which means one of these manufacturing
jobs, and they migrate to some city,
they live in these dorm rooms
where they're just stacked
like cordwood and they
have basically no free time in there.
It's a miserable life,
but they doubled their income.
The economic miracle in Asia is when
people go from $1 a day to $2 a day.
And there's hundreds of millions of
people. You had up China and India,
hundreds of millions of people who
are desperate to earn $2 a day.
It's a doubling of their income.
And when you read these horrible stories,
horrible to Aureus of how, especially
women moving into the big cities, uh,
gone. Joe Can we old can't
Tom or any of the big cities,
how they're living in the
conditions they're working under.
Remember it's a represents a doubling of
their income and it's so much that they
send,
they can send most of that back to their
home village and the home villages are
all living on this kind of income.
And so when we talk about Po, we will
later talking about population in China,
you're now must realize that basically
all of those workers who now have access
to moderately decent
education can compete with us.
There's very few jobs that
we can do and they can't do.
And so we add up to $80 an hour for
blue collar worker are basically in
competition with, with someone
who's very happy and they grumble,
people working for GM grumble
and some of their conditions,
the grumbling could be quite fair.
Uh,
but they're in competition with people
earning $2 a day that wish they would
earn $2 a day.
And in places,
and this is not only our competition,
but jewelry making,
very labor intensive course, uh,
countries with low wage rates,
attract very labor intensive jobs and
handmaking of jewelry is a very labor
intensive job.
And turned out that Bangkok was one
of the centers of jewelry making.
And because it was a center and
requires a fair amount of skill,
the wages actually rose in
Bangkok for these jewelry makers.
And they got up to $8 a day for
a jewelry worker in Bangkok.
And guess what happened?
All the factories moved to
China to back down to $2 a day,
a saving of 75% on your labor costs.
Of course they're going to do it.
And not only China, but Mexico,
all the Makia Dora's the, uh,
the border between Texas
and California and,
and Mexico has a lot of factories.
And because of various trade laws,
they can assemble things and just ship
them across the border with, with low, uh,
low trade tariffs and everything.
And they have the nearly wiped out with
jobs moving to China. And now, of course,
for a while anyway, the conditions that
we're getting little bit better to China.
So the jobs moved to,
I've been reading in newspapers,
who's now competing with China,
one India at a high level, but
Vietnam, Cambodia, you know,
places that are even poor than China
or now even taking jobs away from China
in Romania, which is one of the
poorest countries in Europe. The,
the wages average about $83
a week in your, or so 10,
10,
$12 a day.
When they got into the European Union,
what the Romanian workers do,
they moved out to France, Germany,
England, to get the higher wages that are,
that are available there,
which left a lot of jobs unfilled
in Romania where they get $12 a day,
as I've just said.
So what did the Romanians do?
Imported Chinese who worked for lesson
and fill the jobs as an unlimited number
of peasants in China.
They would love to work in Romania
under almost any kind of of conditions.
And they leave their husbands, their
children. Everybody has left home,
usually under the care of grandparents
who were too old. Uh, themselves to work.
So keep that in mind.
Abject poverty is a dollar a day.
The economic miracle is $2
a day.
Okay.
What does living look like? And these
places that we've been talking about,
Bombay and Shanghai, these are big
places that everybody knows about.
You'll never guess where this is and
you've probably never heard of it.
This is the Capitol of Mauritania. How
many know we're Mauritania is, Oh, good.
It's on the Atlantic coast of Africa.
I should remember to always make sly
grab geographies. You map slides,
but I didn't, it's on the
Atlantic coast. It is the,
the capital is a place called
Norwalk shot. You walk.
Shot is over there somewhere.
And this is the suburbs of new shot.
And what it is is desert.
It's an,
uh,
all of Mauritania is basically a
desert until it rolls into the ocean,
which case it becomes an ocean.
And so in the desert,
all these people live
in a Shanti's of any,
any kind of construction material
of they can, they can find,
uh,
the national government.
The city government does not have the
resources to deal with these people.
At all. So they get no
sanitation. They get no policing,
they get no water. Uh,
there, there's just,
these are called unplanned communities
and they sort of basic don't exist.
But what are they to the government?
They're a source of problem because it's
very poor people who have nothing to
lose revolt. Every so often they
say, you know, you've got something.
We don't have it. We want it. Why is
the government not doing for anything?
So this is a source of
social discontent and the,
and the shanty towns around every big
city in the world are great sources of
social discontent.
So what you see here is a road.
And I've just said they
basically don't have roads.
What happens is that the military in each
of these countries wants to be sure to
be able to control the people.
So every so often they send an bulldozer,
you can sort of see another
road here off to the right.
You get a better one of
these. Uh, they, they, uh,
they just come in one morning and
the people are asleep in there.
Their Shanti's cause they don't have any
jobs. Uh, and very early in the morning,
they just hear this rumble and they
walk outside to find out what it is.
And the bulldozer is two minutes away
from their house and they just go down,
knock out anything that's,
that's in the way.
If you happen to be in
the path that the bulldog,
the military bulldozer and knocks
down now, sorry, sorry, that's gone.
And then the soldiers can, can,
uh, go into these situations.
So the point being that these
enormous dense populations,
which we associate with
Calcutta or Bombay or Shanghai,
Canton, you know, are in fact
almost everywhere in the world now,
including this, oh, sorry. This is,
this is where no shot
meets the Atlantic Ocean.
This is the Atlantic Ocean right here.
This is terrible.
And what do they live on?
Well,
they live on fishing in each of these
little things here that you can see as a
fishing boat,
a little boat that they roll out and
fish and look at how many boats there are
all trying to get the occasional fish.
And that's not a terribly rich
fishing ground of the world.
It's very close to the equator and
there's no big upwelling of nutrients.
So it's not a great big ah, fishing
ground there. But this is how, uh, the,
the people who have competing with each
other for the few fish that are out there
now. So that's the desert.
And here's the jungle.
So this is Brazil in a place that you
may have heard of Sarah Palava peeled
mountain or naked mountain and anybody
has heard of it or seen pictures of this
before. One couple of
people. It's very well known.
So if you travel in Brazil,
all the big cities,
again have shanty towns where people
are desperate for some kind of a job.
So every softened a truck
rolls through and says,
I have some jobs and people just pile
in and I've watched it and they sort of
don't ask how much, where am I
going? What's the kind of work?
A job is like a magic words like Manna
from heaven. They jump in the truck. Well,
one of the places they're taken to is
this place. And this place is way in the,
in the middle of the jungle.
Like a thousand miles from Rio or
South San Paolo and what it is,
it's a mountain that they found gold in.
And normally if you've seen like mining
in the west of the United States and you
know, they have these steam shovels which
have a bucket as big as this whole room
probably, and they each,
each drag of the bucket, uh,
pulls up, you know, hundreds of tons.
I don't know the actual
numbers in Sarah Palava. Uh,
human labor is cheaper than,
uh,
than to buy a steam shovel.
So at each of the little dots are,
is the person and what it is, this is a
pit and they're digging in the mud there.
They carried the mock up. The sluicing
is up here on the top where they have,
you know, sluicing gold is heavier than,
than soil. So they take basically mud,
dump it into a place, water runs
over, it, washes away the mud.
Anything that sticks down falls heavy.
His little flakes,
a little tiny nuggets of gold. That's the
primitive way of doing golden morning.
It just flow water over
mud and there's very,
very low concentration.
You'd get a gold flake there.
So what are these people?
How do they work? This is,
they go down and then climb.
These are uh,
wouldn't ladders and another part,
they climbed down the ladders and they
have a burlap sacks on their back,
the cheapest kind of sack and they go
down and with very primitive implements or
maybe the hands, they take the
earth from the bottom of the pit,
they put it in these packs,
they put the pack on their back and they
climb up the stairs and dump it into
the sluice apparatus and then go back
down. That's there their whole life.
They're miserable wages.
They can't leave cause in the middle of
the jungle they have no way of getting
back to any kind of civilization.
The companies do indeed
provide prostitutes for them.
This whole villages full of prostitutes,
which are the women that come out of
the same surgery and send a truck around
and they have jobs for women.
They jump on with with
little or no questions asked.
And how is the whole thing kept under
control by soldiers with guns or power
militaries with guns.
And here is uh, you know,
moderately typical.
One of the workers has,
have not even the clothes on his back and
there's, you know, huge numbers of them.
They are kept control.
In this particular instance,
the things were looking like they
were going to go out of control.
And again, uh, this, this is,
this is all around the world.
You find situations like this.
Uh,
sometimes I talk about, you know,
it's everywhere in the world. Uh,
if you go up to Mount Everest, so we've
got, what are the ends of the earth?
There's the deserts,
there's the jungles and this Mount
Everest and that just copy down some
statistic of Mt.
Everest.
Just this is how much population
there isn't in the world. Uh,
there's a up high and I
used to mountain climb.
Lot of single footstep can require
eight breaths. You take a step,
you pan eight times and people like me
would be a lot more than eight times on
one particular day and standard in the
couple of months that you can climb with
his 500 climbers waiting
to, to climb up Everest. Uh,
they, the, the places are
littered with dead bodies.
It's littered with oxygen
bottles. I mean, Mt.
Everest is kind of a congestion zone.
It,
it looks like grand central station that
had been sort of cleared out of people
are on many days.
There's 120 dead bodies littering
the top of Mount Everest.
So population has gotten so extreme
that it's not only the big cities,
it's basically everywhere that
you look, uh, uh, uh, people are.
So let's just, uh, conclude, uh, tell
you what a little bit of future, uh,
guessing.
So we know that fertility,
so now we have most of the world,
very high fertility rate
population going gangbusters. Now,
can we dream up a scenario where
this gets better? May get better,
it may not get better.
You know,
things may get to worse until there's
some incredible crisis or things may stay
as they are now, where things may cost
to a, to a soft landing. We don't know.
But let's draw ourselves as scenario
for the soft landing situation.
So one of the things that we
know is that there's very,
very poor be these dollar a day.
People don't limit their births.
And the exact reason for
it we will discuss later.
A lot has to do with education,
that they don't,
a lot of things about how their bodies
work. They don't understand. So they're,
they're afraid of modern contraception, a
lot of issues, which, which we will, uh,
we will discuss.
But we observe around the world that some
increase in standard of living has to
take place for populate for
before people start, uh,
being willing and want
to limit their fertility.
So let's take the minimum situation.
Let's say someone gets one of these $2
a day jobs and that's then they start
thinking differently about
themselves in the world.
There may be in a city where
they get some education,
some awareness of what's
going on in the world.
They want to limit their population.
So let's say that we go from
a dollar a day to $2 a day.
That's incredibly optimistic. That $2 a
day is sufficient, but you'll see what,
where I'm going. That's a doubling
of income of the poor people. Again,
something like a third of the people on
Earth or in this one to $2 a day range.
So you doubled their income and
all of a sudden miracles
happen. Population stops
growing, not real. Oh Way.
Overly optimistic.
Well,
another thing that we know is that when
incomes around the world rise to poor,
people have the smallest rise and the
rich people have the biggest fries.
So if the small people are doubling
their income, what is the whole,
the average of the whole world doing?
It's going to be much more than doubling.
And again, you can pick a, I'm
sure economists have these numbers,
I don't have them.
You can pick whatever number you want.
If in order to raise most of the
world from $1 a day to $2 a day,
I need to double their income, then does
the whole world rises by more than two,
maybe three.
But we can pick any number that we want.
So I've kind of your two facts that
the population of the world is for sure
going to increase by something like
50% before if and when it stabilizes.
We can sort of see ballpark of
50% increase coming and now,
but this AV average standard of living
has to at least double and probably
triple or quadruple or you know, again,
pick almost whatever number you want.
So at the minimum of doubling the
world's, uh, per capita income,
uh, 50% more people are doubling and
the income, it means a three that,
that the gross,
uh,
economy or it has to triple because you
have one and a half times as many people
each earning twice as much.
That's a tripling of the world economy.
If you want to say that, uh,
the world that to double the,
the income or poor people, you have to
triple the whole world world economy,
then that's three times one and a
half or four and a half times as much.
So basically we're looking at an,
at an optimistic scenario for the
future where we come to a soft landing.
And then in order to
come to a soft landing,
we have to have the economy of the world
increased by a factor of three by a
factor of four, four, and half, five, six,
somewhere in that range of numbers.
Now,
technology,
the improvement of technology allows us
to grow our income without not somewhat
less than proportionate increase
in resources. And again,
you can make a wall to guests about
how much technology will improve in the
future so that we can double our
income without quite doubling, uh,
the,
the drain on the world's resources and
the amount of pollution we put into it at
amount of carbon dioxide we put into it.
So we're looking at this enormous increase
in order to come to a soft landing.
We're looking at this,
at least a tripling of the world economy
and something like a tripling of the
pollution in the world to come knock.
So in the world, the, the, uh, uh, the,
the,
the use of resources in the world.
And most people believe that we're at
the limit of what the earth can cope with
in terms of the economy,
which is basically how much
we're taking out of the earth.
We're at the limit right now,
but with population,
we're not going to have a soft landing
unless we triple that at least minimum of
triple that.
So that's,
that's the significance of
this population issue that,
you know, can the earth cope with a
tripling of the economic activity on it.
I left my crystal ball home,
so you're going to,
you are definitely going to find out
the answer to that question. Okay.
Next time we will continue.